- So you're also in the hit
show, "Ghosts," obviously.
So your character is
a closeted gay soldier
from the American Revolution.
- Yeah. Yeah.
- Were you just like,
"This is so funny and
awesome, I wanna do this"?
- Yes, exactly.
- [Kelly] It just seems like a fun role.
- Yeah, it is. It's so fun.
It was, you know, it's like
when you kind of get that
as like your character breakdown
when you're gonna go to audition,
like the connection bells
don't immediately go right off,
but then you see this and you're like,
"Oh, this is so funny. I have to do this."
And it's been this like really fun journey
of playing this like
pompous, ridiculous man who,
I was in the closet for 21 years,
and he was in the closet for 250 years.
(all laughing)
You know what I mean?
Like some stuff was ready to come out.
- It took a minute.
I know, he's this dead
guy and he still hasn't
come out.
- Figuring it out.
- Yeah, exactly.
(all laughing)
- Oh, my god, that's awesome.
I love you. I love all
the projects you're doing.
- Thank you so much.
- Congratulations.
- Thank you.